[Music]
so I'm glad you brought up Sheree and I
want to get to that in a second but I
said at the beginning I wasn't going to
ask you about the past again but I think
it's um
something that I get people ask me about
like you know when they'll ask me when
did you wake up to this stuff and start
talking about some of the stuff so for
you was there actually a moment like was
it when you left Somalia and then from
then on this idea about individualism
and all this really stuck with you or
was it as your travels continued and
some of the some of this what are the
bad things that happened to now some of
the good things like was there really a
moment where your ideology guy
crystallized it was gradual and I didn't
have an ideology I just you know felt
the pain of being told you can't do this
you have to do that and being resentful
and feeling powerless and thinking well
I can't I would like to do something I
don't want to marry this man because I
don't want to end up like my mother and
like all these other women I've grown up
around who feels powerless emotionally
trapped in these who and who who really
wonder what is life all about why all
this suffering when is there something I
can do as an individual to be different
and to make my own circumstances
different so when I went to Holland and
I found people and a society and a
culture that actually made it possible
and enhance all of that I started to
think about not so much you know develop
an account ideology but just try and
understand what's this all about and in
my years in light and I went to the
University of Leiden no safe spaces none
of that nonsense existed
III got introduction to all the various
philosophies that preceded the one that
we enjoyed at that point in time in the
Netherlands and then 9/11 happened and
you know that brought the issue of Islam
for me as a Muslim as a former Muslim at
the time I identified as a Muslim and so
I found myself in 2001 2002 thinking
about okay how does always relate to me
and what ways where do I stand in this
yeah okay so so from there then let's go
back now to Sharia and today
and political Islam how do we talk about
this in a way that that's not going to
make people crazy we've already got the
idea of ideas and people that these are
different things and you've already
talked about that there are a certain
amount of course of Muslims that are
good people as you said you don't even
know what that number is it could be a
much bigger number than people might
think we we have we don't know but how
do we how do we explain the dangers of
what political Islam is without getting
lost in the mess we use the tools that
we use to explain other facts and other
dangers as long as you're consistent if
you are studying HIV you have to talk
you have to learn something about
viruses and you have to know something
about infections and you have to know
something about blood to blood
transmissions and you know all the ways
that that virus behaves if you're
studying cancers and other facts malaria
all of that you've got to know
everything about the causes the vectors
and all the other environmental issues
that accessor bait the problem with
Islam I find that very often we talk
about symptoms we talk about the
environment we talk about
disenfranchised young men we talk about
countries that feel that because they
have autocratic you know they have
dictatorships that maybe the populations
acting out in assembly but we hardly
ever talk about the cooperation and as
far as I'm concerned if we want to
defeat what it is that makes
Isis Islamic State of Iraq and Syria is
so attractive and al Qaeda and all these
other groups so attractive we will not
be able to do that without learning
something about the life and legacy of
Muhammad the founder of Islam about part
of that legacy is the Quran what is it
what is it that he says was revealed to
me and how does that operate in the
day-to-day lives of people yeah the
leadership the Saudi Arabian government
spent billions of dollars spreading part
of that legacy across the entire world
that is an activity that's now that's an
activity to Islamize non Islamic
societies and to strengthen Islam or
radical Islam or political Islam within
majority Muslim societies so if we don't
understand if we don't scrutinize these
activities and don't analyze them
properly we will always be changing the
symptoms yeah and this so this is what
we see when we see that Germany that the
amount of mosques in Germany that are
funded by Saudi Arabia is up by some I
don't know what the percentages but it's
some crazy percentage and that they're
teaching these ideas so what what is the
goal then when they say we're you know
what what is the goal of Dawa is it
truly to turn these Western countries
into Islamic nations to have a bunch of
westernized people actually suddenly
living under Sharia law it's to Islam
eyes and you know the president of
Turkey IDO on it's very explicit about
it when he's speaking in Turkish he
wants to Islamize Europe he advises
immigrants Muslim immigrants to have
more children because he thinks that's
the fastest way yeah and government's
like that of Saudi Arabia and Qatar and
Kuwait Lee Kump a lot of money into
Western societies and target immigrant
groups and asked them not to assimilate
because to assimilate means less
Islamization and to create these
parallel societies where they live by
what I call Sharia light and Sharia like
always that we're trying to cover up
women and having people establishing
Sharia councils where marriage and
divorce laws and laws of custody women
are persuaded not to take advantage of
or to recognize the normal secular laws
that progress so this is literally a set
of laws that exists sort of parallel to
our our regular second ORS but it
replaces them and this is what people
certain people are living under yeah
it's now become a reality and ever
larger numbers of Muslims adopting this
sharia light and this idea
at some point Europe is going to be in
so much and the West can be turned
against itself to become Islamic now
what we see is there are those groups
who use force and violence they use
terrorism and then there are the
government's and the legitimate they're
called legitimate because they are not
using violence that at least that's how
their attendances been working within
the system to expand the number of
people who accept willingly that these
sharia light laws applied to them so
they create parallel communities or
parallel societies now are they going to
really succeed in their goal of Islam
izing Europe I don't know I hope not I
don't think so but they are trying yeah
and I think there's nothing wrong in
recognizing the fact that they're
actually trying yeah so do we get lost
in too much of the violent I mean if you
were to ask the average person who do
you know who doesn't know that much
about this they would say well I'm
mostly concerned because I see trucks
driving into people in Sweden and
shootings in Paris and the pulse
nightclub in Orlando etc etc but that
that really may be a distraction from
from really what's going on like do
these things work together are the
jihadis and the Islamist even though
you're saying they have totally
different yeah the ideologies are
different are they somehow include well
our Liberal government do what I think
primarily government must do which is
protect people from terrorist activity
so we have intelligence communities that
are monitoring individuals and groups
who are planning the next terrorist
attack and I think that should continue
but the rest of us who are not
monitoring terrorists right we should
understand the process before the jihad
so before a guy jumps in a car in a
truck with a knife in his hand on a gun
in his hand you've got to understand
what it how is it that this man came to
this conclusion he's going to close
strangers people he doesn't know what is
it and when you look at the history of
all the people who've been capped and
were able to talk about it they just say
I'm doing it because I believe
that it's my religion they believe that
they are going to heaven for doing it
and the more you listen to them the more
you compare the notes to what they hear
in mosques and what start at Islamic
schools what is preached sometimes on
the street it is all this non-violent
activity that is taking full advantage
exploiting the freedom of association
freedom of religion the freedom of
speech to spread this idea among people
that is I think when we as a society
should wake up to this and say wait a
second what is this message what are
these people teaching which groups and
individuals are they targeting what is
their objective and can we develop a
counter narrative and we have that
counter narrative we don't even have to
develop it we just need to market it to
those individuals and groups that they
target yeah I'm perfectly happy to talk
to and this is these are the people that
I would like to talk to the prisoners
the immigrants everywhere and tell them
listen you come from a country where
Sharia is actually the law and you fled
that country it's not a great life you
are now in a free country do you know
what the two different philosophies and
the two different principles are that
each of these countries is founded on
this is what Sharia countries that are
founded on the Sharia principle this is
what they look like in real life life is
miserable miserable for women it's
miserable for religious minorities it's
miserable for gays it's miserable for
men it's resident it's miserable for
most of the Muslim people that live
there
I just want to be free forget I think in
this case a good example is just forget
the minorities you think of the majority
majority it's immeasurable for everyone
you look at these other nation states
that are founded on the principle of
freedom of equality of tolerance hey
life may not be what heaven is painted
out to be where you can have 72 virgins
at a time sorry yes and drink quietly
much thank you very much so it's not you
know that's fantastical in your topic
and in my view kind of
you know really stupid yeah but I
wouldn't even use the word stupid I'll
just say hey it might not be as business
ID as that yeah but you know you're free
to do what you want life is stable it's
predictable you can have your friends in
your community you can build you can
have a passion and develop it you can
indulge your senses art music love for
cooking love for others it's so much
more attractive in fact when I came to
Holland and here in America often I
think but this is paradise yeah I want
to live as long as possible yeah I don't
want to go to this promise paradise and
so we have to start to talking to the
same audiences about is there really an
afterlife was Muhammad really moral
should you really follow everything that
Muhammad said to this day so are there
some things that are unacceptable I mean
it's a few centuries later right and I
should at least be able to talk about it
yeah at the very least and we should
talk about this in elementary schools in
high schools in universities that's
where young people are we should use
cultural tools the cinema music
everything to try and influence them to
make these choices but we've got to make
them aware of this other choice the
principles of freedom because that's not
where they come from they don't know it
so is that really where the West has
failed that you know your phrase about
the tolerance of intolerance and you're
making a very clear case that they want
to use our tolerance against us and yet
our tolerance is so built-in to the west
of course we have problems and there's
you know people we have monetary just
you know people have all sorts a
different amount of money and all kinds
of problems and there of course are
still people that are racist and all
those things yes but that are basic
tolerance is now being turned on us and
we haven't done a good job selling it
right because we do find out that a lot
of these jihadists yeah
they don't come from poor families many
of them come from well-to-do families
and many of them are well-educated in
all the things yeah which if we would
push that idea out more perhaps it would
give us a little more credit in what
we're trying to do and what we're trying
to do yeah I think it is a company
that it is not like we talked about the
symptoms it's not because people are
pouring in fact I think people are poor
because if the principle of Sharia is
the prevailing principle people will be
poor
you're not Sharia is not about making
money fear is about trying to adhere to
a set of rules very blindly that are
economically unfriendly and that
increase inequality and we look at the
position of women if you lock up women
that when you keep them ignorant you're
going to have a society that's extremely
poor and with great inequality with
Sharia it may be well intended whatever
the intentions are I can't see the well
in there but you are also creating
circumstances for the abuse of power
power is concentrated in the hands of
very few people the clergymen who
believe that they can tell you the
difference between right and wrong who
put themselves on God's seat so it's
just it opens the doors ultimate pure
exploitation yeah and we in the West we
fail to sell and I think part of it is
because the people present-day
Westerners didn't do the fighting you
know they were not the young hungry
scrappy men that made this country the
other ones who inherited it after
several generations so people don't know
I remember being in Holland and seeing
you know this this idea of freedom was
it was the identity of the Dutchman at
the almost a biological identity took it
so for granted they couldn't understand
why people didn't just adapt yeah yeah
they didn't think that it is they didn't
see that it was something that they had
learned from their parents and their
environment their parents had learned
from their parents and it I always
compare it to you know wealthy children
of wealthy family businesses the first
generation is the one that makes the
money next generation kind of knows what
the first generation went through there
conscious of the fact that they have to
carry these responsibilities forward
ultimately a generation comes but just
spends and doesn't know where it all
comes from yeah and part of me thinks
you know we're living at a time when
lots of Westerners are really spending
this legacy of freedom and they don't
know they don't know what it is not to
be free they don't know what it what
inequality really means we're talking
about inequality of outcomes yeah I'm
talking about this idea that is
ingrained in people outside of the West
that they have an inferior spot and that
that's their spot yeah so as women
you're inferior in a caste system you
belong to your caste and you can never
come out of it and there's no social
mobility or if there's social mobility
it's because of Western influence it's
not an organic thing that comes out of
these cultures so Western us just think
you know people will come to it yeah and
it's just it's just simply not true
it's not true and it's dangerous because
if you don't if we don't engage in a
dowel for freedoms we're going to be
overtaken by the dollar for Sharia
[Music]
you
[Music]